[Music]
so how much do you really know about
snoopy
[Music]
there's a whole lot more to this pup
than meets the eye
it's time to play the snoopy scoop
first up do you know where snoopy was
born
was it charlie brown's house
don't be nervous you're gonna like it
here a pumpkin patch
[Music]
for daisy hill farm
the answer
daisy hill farm but did you also know he
wasn't born alone
how many brothers and sisters do you
think snoopy has
is it 2
5 or seven
and the answer is
five way to go
think you can name them all
there's spike andy
marbles olaf
and belle
oh hey snoopy
snoopy's got a lot of talent like
dancing
painting
or going on incredible adventures
but can you guess his other secret
talent is it playing the guitar hey kid
can i have my badminton racket back
juggling
or being a master magician magic i'll
believe it when i see it
if you guessed master magician you're
right
he's one dog that can always learn new
tricks
[Music]
and speaking of hidden talents here's a
question from charlie brown
that's me
true or false
one of charlie brown's favorite things
to do is play baseball
hey can someone throw me the ball
it's true
[Music]
i've given up two hits and i haven't
even thrown a pitch say looks like you
already knew a lot about snoopy but
there's always something new to discover
thanks for playing the snoopy scoop
the snoopy show
only on apple tv plus